ici Céline Galipeau en direct de Kiev il
y a un an la ville s'est réveillée au
son des sirènes Vladimir Poutine lançait
ses soldats sur l'Ukraine pour ce qui
devait être une opération éclair mais
rien ne s'est pas assez comme prévu et
aujourd'hui les Ukrainiens avec l'aide
de l'Occident continuent de résister
bienvenue à cette édition spéciale du
Téléjournal l'Ukraine un an de guerre
les manœuvres militaires se poursuivent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mesdames messieurs oui ça reste
difficile de revoir toutes ces images
l'Ukraine n'a pas craqué et triomphera
des troupes et de la terreur russe a
affirmait aujourd'hui le président wolo
dimirzelinski mais à quel prix l'Ukraine
ne donne pas de chiffres sur ces pertes
militaires mais selon la Norvège la
guerre aurait déjà fait 100.000 morts et
c'est sans compter les 30 à 40 000
civils qui auraient perdu la vie comment
oublier par exemple les tortures et les
exactions à bout de chat ou encore la
destruction de la ville de Mario Paul le
bilan sera encore plus lourd côté russe
où on parle de 180000 morts ou blessés
d'ailleurs Vladimir Poutine a déposé des
fleurs aujourd'hui sur la tombe du
soldat inconnu à Moscou alors ce soir ou
en sont les combats dans quel état
d'esprit sont les ukrainiens et comment
envisager une fin de ce conflit nous
ferons le point avec nos correspondants
Jean-François Bélanger est à carquive
Tamara Alteresco est près la frontière
russe en Géorgie et Marie-Eve Bédard
elle est au Royaume-Uni
et je commence avec vous Jean-François
vous revenez de la ligne de France on
redoute une nouvelle offensive massive
de la Russie on pensait même que ça
pouvait se passer là pour cet
anniversaire comment est-ce que c'est
vécu sur le terrain
étant donné le déséquilibre des forces
au début de cette affrontement les
Ukrainiens considèrent que le simple
fait d'avoir réussi à tenir un an face à
la Russie c'est constitué déjà une
victoire en soi aujourd'hui on a passé
la journée en fait avec des forces
déployées sur le terrain le 225ème
bataillon de la 127e brigade de défense
territoriale dans le nord-est de
l'Ukraine très près de la ligne de front
on peut pas vous dire où exactement pour
des raisons de sécurité et cette unité
là donc a lancé une attaque contre
contre un dépôt de munitions des forces
ruses donc pour les Ukrainiens pas
question de rester là passivement
attendre une éventuelle attaque des
Russes on fait tout pour la faire
dérailler on fait tout pour empêcher
qu'elle se produise et vous savez les
Ukrainiens ils ont beaucoup appris au
cours de cette année-là et ils ont
beaucoup appris surtout à tenir à
profiter
chacune de la lourdeur de l'armée russe
et se considère aujourd'hui comme la
meilleure force armée d'Europe et puis
considère que ben ils continuent de le
prouver tous les jours sur le terrain
dans le nord-est de l'Ukraine des
paysages qui ne trompent pas une terre
qui porte l'empreinte de la guerre la
mort et la destruction dans toutes les
directions
seul protection ici les tranchées que
nous fait visiter Sania non guerre hayax
c'est très dangereux chaque minute
chaque seconde dit-il tout change très
vite
il explique que tout le monde sur la
ligne de France Satan une grande
offensive russe mais les Ukrainiens sont
près dit-il on ne va pas les laisser
passer
la vie offrant se déroule beaucoup sous
terre pour se protéger se réchauffer
meublé latente souvent interminable
entre les missions mais si le conflit
entre dans sa deuxième année Nikola et
lui n'a pas vu le temps passer
tout est allé très vite dit-il l'été
l'automne l'hiver est presque terminé
maintenant on a été annoncé notre
travail
nous sommes ici en première ligne les
positions russes ne sont qu'à 3 km d'ici
dans cette direction et ça tire tous les
jours
[Musique]
si elle a parfois des apparences de
Première Guerre mondiale avec ses
tranchées la guerre d'Ukraine est aussi
très moderne les combats ici se
déroulent souvent par écran interposé
nous sommes dans le poste de
commandement du 225e bataillon de la
127e brigade de défense territoriale
un emplacement gardez secret pour des
raisons évidentes de sécurité
les services de renseignements ont
localisé un dépôt d'armes côté russe
le commandant ukrainien mieux connu sous
son nom de guerre circo et bien décidé à
le détruire pour faire dérailler
l'offensive ennemi les coordonnées sont
transmises au poste de tir au quartier
général on observe le résultat en direct
sur grand écran
mission accomplie
depuis la Deuxième Guerre mondiale les
tactiques russes n'ont pas changé dit-il
elles sont basées sur l'envoi massif de
chair à canon l'armée ukrainienne est
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus mobile plus
flexible et plus inventive selon lui
nous leur infligeons beaucoup plus de
dommages que l'inverse ajoute-t-il
le commandant olegara à la rencontre des
hommes qui ont mené à bien lattes pour
les féliciter une mission d'artillerie
confiait un équipage de tente un usage
inhabituel ici on fait avec ce que l'on
a en l'occurrence avec un vieux t64 de
l'air soviétique
il a été fabriqué à carcive différent
Léonides son commandant mais le temps
qui se l'avoue son véhicule n'est plus
tout jeune aussi tous ici attendent avec
impatience les chars et blindé
occidentaux
les Léopards de allemands comme ce
premier par le Canada nos hommes
apprennent vite dit-il donnez-nous les
et on s'occupe du reste
tous ici n'ont donc aucun doute sur
l'issue de la guerre une victoire
ukrainienne car l'inverse est impensable
quant au calendrier du style il dépendra
fortement des armes qu'il recevront et
de leurs dates de livraison ici
Jean-François Bélanger Radio-Canada près
de la ligne de France dans le nord-est
de l'Ukraine
alors où en sont les combats en Ukraine
le front est très étendu il fait presque
1000 km de la région de harkish jusqu'à
Carson au sud et c'est la ville de
Barmon dans le Dan basque en est
l'épicentre actuellement cette bataille
dure depuis des mois des combats
acharnés très meurtriers les Russes
tentent aussi de bloquer autour les
voies d'approvisionnement aux soldat
ukrainien la base arrière de châssivia
est à 5 km environ et la ville est
bombardée depuis des semaines on y est
allé la plupart des 15000 habitants ont
déjà quitté la région mais certains y
vivent encore et ils sont divisés vous
allez voir envers les Russes
jour après jour la pression devient de
plus en plus forte
les échanges de tirs sont incessants
dans les rues de châssivia les immeubles
sont désertés il n'y a plus aucun enfant
les parcs sont abandonnés
sur la place centrale devant le palais
de la culture quelques résidences sont
venus chercher de l'aide humanitaire de
la farine des vivres il se dépêche
ensuite de se mettre à l'abri
les avions les explosions tout tremblent
et ça ne cesse jamais non
c'est surtout difficile mentalement on a
peur bien sûr dit-elle mais on doit
l'endurer j'espère que nous ennemis
serons punis après tout ce qu'ils ont
fait
la ligne de front n'est qu'à quelques
kilomètres sur la colline un canon
ukrainien ces deux-là qu'on tire vers
les positions russes et verbarmouth la
ville est aussi un point de
ravitaillement pour les troupes
nous nous arrêtons à l'un des derniers
magasins encore ouvert on y trouve des
biens essentiels de la nourriture aussi
et dans le fond une chanson de Céline
Dion joue à la radio
[Musique]
la propriétaire nous explique que c'est
maintenant la panique mais que cela va
peut-être s'arranger elle se demande si
elle doit partir ou pas pourtant il y a
Ginko petrovenant ne voit pas d'un
mauvais œil la progression des Russes
pourquoi est-ce que j'aurais peur
dit-elle on a vécu avec eux toute notre
vie mon père et tu craignais ma mère est
russe mon mari est même là en ce moment
il ne peut plus revenir
dans cette région russophone de
l'Ukraine ils ne sont plus nombreux mais
certains n'ont pas la même perception du
conflit
Nadia et Oleg sidorenco sont eux aussi
pro russe pas question de quitter cette
maison qu'ils habitent depuis toujours
mon époque-moi
on vivait ensemble russe et ukrainien
d'inadiejda c'était bien avant pourquoi
ils veulent nous diviser maintenant pour
eux l'Ukraine fait partie de la Russie
même s'ils ne le disent pas ouvertement
par crainte de représailles
oui je suis née j'ai grandi en Union
soviétique et je n'ai jamais compris
nous dit-elle la séparation d'Ukraine un
atlas du temps de l'URSS traîne au bord
de la fenêtre
en laissant amer ils ont le sentiment
d'avoir été négligés oubliés par les
autorités ukrainiennes depuis
l'indépendance
vous avez vu notre ville dit son mari
tout est détruit il n'y a plus d'usine
comme le reste du pays d'ailleurs
c'était bien différent il y a 30 ans
à l'autre bout de la ville la
distribution se termine Tamara et sa
fille ont reçu plusieurs sacs de farine
pour elle et pour leurs voisins de quoi
tenir plusieurs jours mais elles n'ont
que de la colère envers le peuple russe
pourrir Diala après tout ce qu'ils nous
ont fait tout ça c'est la faute du mot
dipotine sans lui il n'y aurait jamais
eu de guerre ici chacun a fait son choix
les deux camps cohabitent encore mais
peut-être plus pour longtemps le sort de
la ville se dessine en ce moment même à
quelques kilomètres plus à l'est
en tout cas on ne donnait pas cher de
cette armée ukrainienne il y a un an les
observateurs s'attendaient même à ce
qu'elle soit balayées en quelques jours
mais la grande armée russe a accumulé
les échecs et leur tactiques problèmes
de logistique troupes peu motivés bref
les Ukrainiens résistent Jean-François
parlait avec le soutien bien sûr des
Occidentaux mais pour espérer gagner
cette guerre ils ont besoin de plus
d'équipements lourds des chars d'assaut
notamment ce qui leur a finalement été
accordée le Canada a promis d'ailleurs
quatre chars léopard alors Marie-Ève
vous êtes à rail au Royaume-Uni vous
étiez en Pologne il y a quelques jours
où les soldats canadiens aient déjà à la
formation des Ukrainiens
depuis le début du mois de février il y
a quelques 30 soldats canadiens qui
participent à l'opération d'une fire
c'est cette opération canadienne
d'entraînement des forces militaires
ukrainiennes c'est une opération qui a
commencé bien avant l'invasion par la
Russie de l'Ukraine en février dernier
dès les combats qui ont éclaté dans le
don de basse en 2014 en fait au
lendemain on avait pris une pause avec
l'invasion maintenant ces programmes
d'entraînement reprennent et le plus
important en ce moment Céline je vous
dirais c'est la préparation de ces
temps-ci qui vont pouvoir enfin opérer
ces chars léopard que demandait
l'Ukraine donc les Canadiens ils sont
pour s'assurer que ces soldats soient
prêts avec ce nouvel équipement c'est un
entraînement vous allez le voir qui se
fait en accéléré parce qu'ils sont
fraîchement débarqués des lignes de
front dans l'est du pays et ils doivent
y retourner au plus vite pour poursuivre
les combats
ils sont encore loin des champs de
bataille mais les Ukrainiens ont enfin
mis la main sur le volant des chars
léopards 2
pour des raisons de sécurité nous ne
pouvons vous montrer leur visage mais
ils sont une centaine de soldats
fraîchement arrivés des lignes de front
à l'est de l'Ukraine
major nos soldats aiment vraiment facile
à conduire il assure un bon niveau de
protection et un très bon moteur
la capitaine Britney ski ghisis commande
la trentaine de soldats canadiens qui
viennent tout juste d'être déployés en
Pologne pour former les campus
ukrainiens
si elle conduit une simulation d'attaque
pour illustrer ce que l'on attendait
communications claires des gestes
rapides et synchronisés une
concentration totale
la grande majorité des soldats en
formation sont des tankistes
d'expérience maintenant après un an de
guerre aux commandes de vieux chars de
type soviétique il s'ajusteront
rapidement leur nouvelle équipement
assure leur commandant
sont qualifiés dit-il ils ont
l'expérience de nos chars à leurs
entraînement sur ces chars là et plus
facile ce sont des tankistes c'est comme
de conduire une Mercedes et de passer à
une Volkswagen
pour leur permettre de retourner au
combat le plus vite possible la
formation a été condensée dans le temps
au maximum fait valoir le commandant
adjoint du centre d'entraînement des
Polonais qui nous a demandé de ne pas
publier son nom
en Pologne l'inquiétude est profonde ici
on redoute sérieusement que les
ambitions territoriales devraient
au-delà des frontières de l'Ukraine
voisine la Pologne a militait sans
réserve pour la livraison de Charles
léopard à l'Ukraine
les chars léopard offrent aux Ukrainiens
un avantage stratégique qu'il réclamait
depuis les tout début de la guerre mais
il ne faut pas croire prévient-on ici
que ça va changer la situation sur le
terrain du jour au lendemain
formation accélérée ou pas les tankistes
ukrainien n'en sont pas encore à pouvoir
tester les tirs de leur futur engins de
guerre pour le moment c'est sur ces
simulateurs qu'ils doivent acquérir de
l'expérience sous le regard avisé de
leurs instructeurs Canadiens ils
apprennent à piloter débusquer l'ennemi
et tirer avec précision
le majeur rodac ne ménage pas son
enthousiasme et sa reconnaissance envers
ses alliés mais son jugement final du
léopard 2 il le réserve pour plus tard
c'est trop tôt pour parler de
supériorité sur notre ennemi il faut
pouvoir se servir de la technologie au
combat dit-il sur la ligne de front
quand nous verrons les résultats nous en
tirerons des conclusions
ils seront de retour au front dans
quelques semaines à peine une unité de
temps kyste transformée il rejoindront
une armée ukrainienne qui tranquillement
devient compatible avec les forces de
l'OTAN
pour l'Ukraine c'est peut-être en soi
une victoire importante
on fait tout pour avoir cette victoire
après la pause comment les Ukrainiens
vont-ils tenir une entrevue avec la
députée laissez vassilingo
[Musique]
Kiev est bien loin du front dans la
capitale les Ukrainiens essaient de
vivre le plus normalement possible les
gens vont travailler les magasins les
cafés sont ouverts la guerre est quand
même dans tous les esprits il y a eu des
sirènes d'alerte aujourd'hui et on
sentait plus de nervosité parce qu'on
redoutait en ce premier anniversaire de
nouvelles attaques de Moscou où en sont
donc les Ukrainiens vont-ils tenir j'en
ai parlé avec la députée de l'opposition
laisser avastillanco qui est une des
voies de ce conflit depuis le début et
qui partagent maintenant son temps entre
l'Ukraine et le pays où sont réfugiés
ses enfants je l'ai rencontré dans un
café du centre-ville
[Musique]
on est vraiment content de vous revoir
et je vais vous demander juste comment
vous allez après cette année de guerre
c'est une année difficile mais moi j'ai
appris beaucoup de moi-même de mes
propres capacités je pense que c'est la
même chose pour plusieurs de ses
premiers pour toute la nation
ukrainienne et quel est l'état d'esprit
des
Ukrainiens aujourd'hui vous diriez
on fait tout pour avoir cette victoire
parce qu'il doit y avoir une certaine
fatigue quand même oui c'est la fatigue
c'est
j'en ai marre c'est
peut-être une certaine tristesse une
certaine dépression à une déprime mais
on en a pas le droit à ce moment de se
laisser faire par ses émotions on se
regroupe on se mobilise et on continue
de
d'exister d'exister et de nous défendre
et de travailler
n'importe dans quelle
moyen pour pour rapprocher cette
victoire
vous vivez avec ces sirènes vous vous on
s'habitue à vivre dans la vie vous savez
j'ai passé les dernières je pense deux
ou trois semaines
hors de l'Ukraine et quand j'étais
revenu et
le premier nuit il y avait les sirènes
j'ai sorti sur le balcon et c'est très
étrange mais le son ça m'a dit bon tu es
vraiment à la maison c'est juste un
aspect de devis normal à ce moment à qui
et je dirais que de venir habitué à ces
choses dangereuses périlleuse comme les
attaques aéréales comme les sirènes qui
marque les attaques
c'est pas pour vous ça du tout on
recense déjà plus de 60 000 crimes de
guerre on a beaucoup entendu parler de
la torture des viols mais il y a
également des enfants des enfants qui
sont pas épargnés il y aurait 16 000
enfants
Ukrainiens qui auraient été déportés la
Russie qu'est-ce que ça nous dit de la
stratégie des Russes ça veut dire que
les Russes sont en train de commettre le
crime de la génocide contre les
Ukrainiens parce que exactement cela
retirez les enfants de leur famille
retirer les enfants de leur pays séparer
les familles
c'est sont tous des signes du crime de
génocide la communauté internationale a
une responsabilité de prévenir le crime
de la génocide et on ne l'a pas fait le
crime de la génocide et entrain de se
dérouler à ce moment en Ukraine et les
Russes sont responsables de cela
[Musique]
quand on se promène vers l'est vers la
ligne de front on voit toutes ces villes
détruites des villages entiers il y a
plus une maison qui tient debout et on
se demande comment est-ce qu'après ça va
pouvoir être reconstruit pour moi
la destruction c'est c'est pas juste la
l'importance et le besoin de trouver
l'argent pour
reconstruire les maisons les écoles les
autoroutes pour moi ce sont des vies
humaines qui ont été détruites donc ces
maisons il y avait des gens qui
habitaient il y avait des familles qui
habitaient où sont ces familles ils sont
soit mort ou ils sont ils ont dû
déménager 7 millions de déplacés
hors de l'Ukraine en Europe au Canada
aux États-Unis et partout au monde et
encore 8 millions de déplacés en Ukraine
des Ukrainiens qui ont dû quitter leur
maison à l'est de l'Ukraine tout au long
de des frontières de la guerre de combat
et qui ont dit déménager soit acquises
soit plus loin vous vous êtes une
députée de l'opposition au début de la
guerre vous avez appuyé volo diverski
après tous ces sacrifices après tout ce
qui s'est passé depuis un an est-ce que
c'est encore le cas et absolument vous
savez le Président il a
montré
son dédication à son pays à son peuple
c'était très clair il n'a pas pris le
taxi il a comme les américains lui
proposait et pour moi c'est c'est un
grand signe qui me dit que c'est
vraiment un président
ukrainien qui travaille pour le crâne
pour le bien de son peuple pour le bien
de son pays avec son président l'âge je
crois vraiment la victoire est-ce que
vous pensez qu'après une réconciliation
entre les deux pays et maintenant
possible
ça sera après la victoire on devrait
penser à ça parce que toute façon les
Russes se sont nos voisins
ils vont pas tout d'un coup tous
disparaitre
bon il reste donc on devrait trouver des
moyens comment comment est habiter avec
mais avant que ça commence
on doit entendre un simple pardon
pardonnez-moi
on doit avoir des excuses on doit avoir
comme avec les réparations pour les
bâtiments on doit avoir ce sentiment de
de la nation russe qu'ils ont fait tort
qu'ils ont fait mal est-ce que les
Ukrainiens est-ce que leurs sentiments
ont changé est-ce que tout ce qui s'est
passé fait qu'ils sont
plus résilient encore
quand il y a un problème tel que la
guerre ça c'est un grand grand problème
pour survivre on s'unit donc il y avait
eu cette unité totale à un niveau
national avec cette unité on a découvert
des valeurs qui ont été toujours là je
pense mais ils ont été redécouvertes et
une deux c'est vraiment cette résilience
après tous les sacrifices les gens ils
doivent se dire on peut pas arrêter
maintenant il faut aller jusqu'au bout
quoi parce que on n'a pas d'autre choix
on a qu'une seule Ukraine
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
et plus tard nous irons en Géorgie voir
comment après un an de sanctions
occidentales la Russie arrive malgré
tout à tenir le coup
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre notre émission sur
l'Ukraine voici en rafale quelques
nouvelles qui ont retenu notre attention
aujourd'hui avec jean-Sébastien Cloutier
un nombre record de
4875 réfugiés sont entrés au Canada par
le chemin Roxane au cours du seul mois
de janvier l'ambassadeur américain à
Ottawa a beau laisser entendre que
régler cette question n'est pas
prioritaire pour les États-Unis Justin
Trudeau répète qu'elle est à l'ordre du
jour dans mes conversations directement
avec le président Biden il comprend à
quel point c'est une priorité pour le
Canada la communauté micmac de El
cibouktou au Nouveau-Brunswick se remet
d'un important incendie qui a blessé
gravement une personne et en a jeté
quelques dizaines d'autres à la rue la
nuit dernière
une douzaine d'appartements se trouvait
dans l'immeuble ravagé par les flammes
toute la journée de nombreux dons de
vêtements et de nourriture ont été
déposés au Centre communautaire local
pour les sinistrés il y a pas
d'inquiétude à avoir la Caisse de dépôt
et de placement du Québec a conclu 2022
avec un rendement négatif de
5,6%, c'est sa première année de perte
depuis 2008 la chute des marchés
obligataires provoqués par les hausses
des taux d'intérêt à notamment fait mal
une situation où est-ce que simplement
garder ces titres-là d'obligation
jusqu'à l'échéance on récupérera
automatiquement on le voit déjà donc il
y a pas il y a pas il y a pas de quoi
perdre le sommeil la valeur du bas de
l'Inde des Québécois a diminué de 18
milliards de dollars ici jean-Sébastien
Cloutier Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]
nous revenons à notre édition spéciale
et on vous retrouve Tamara vous êtes
donc en Géorgie tout près de la
frontière avec la Russie vous avez
d'ailleurs couvert ce pays pendant 4 ans
mais Radio-Canada ni à plus accès mais
comment est-ce que les Russes vivent
cette guerre
c'est difficile Céline de lire la pensée
d'un peuple qui marche pas regardez ces
images du grand stade où je Niki à
Moscou cette semaine avec Vladimir
Poutine c'est un véritable Levine
patriotique c'est sûr que c'est le genre
d'événements qui est orchestré en Russie
pour donner l'illusion d'un peuple qui
se range vraiment derrière son président
mais moi les gens à qui je parle me
disent qu'ils sont très inquiets
inquiets parce que ils sont nourris de
scénario catastrophes à la télévision et
on est obligé de constater un an plus
tard qui est encore beaucoup de gens on
peut pas dire une majorité mais beaucoup
de gens en Russie pas qu'ils soutiennent
la guerre mais qui sont convaincus
qu'elle est légitime et qu'elle est
nécessaire malgré le coût humain immense
et ceux qui s'opposent me disent on se
sent carrément impuissant je les cite on
me dit on souffre en silence parce qu'on
peut pas s'opposer c'est trop dangereux
donc les gens partent quand ils en ont
les moyens il y a des la communauté
russe qui poussent un peu partout ici
dans la région en Arménie au Kazakhstan
ici même en Géorgie depuis un an Céline
on estime à un million le nombre de
Russes qui ont fui leur pays c'est un
exode historique pour la Russie ouais
c'est vraiment énorme et dès les
premières bombes la Russie a subi on le
sait des sanctions inédites et pourtant
Tamara l'économie elle tient le coup ce
qu'on a beaucoup de mal à s'expliquer en
Occident
mais c'est pas que les sanctions
fonctionnent pas c'est qu'il faut le
voir à long terme les sanctions les
véritables sanctions celles qui vont
faire mal à la Russie et dans l'espoir
de stopper sa machine de guerre elles
viennent tout juste d'entrer en vigueur
c'est c'est progressif là je parle du
plafonnement du prix du pétrole les
limites sur les importations de gaz et
faut pas oublier que la Russie c'est un
pays qui a une réserve
faramineuse et donc elle peut se
rabattre là-dessus et pour ce qui est
des boycottes et des sanctions sur les
exportations vers la Russie ben la
Russie s'ajuste et comme vous allez
pouvoir le voir dans notre portage ici
c'est une plaque tournante pour
l'acheminement des biens y compris des
biens sanctionnés
c'est la frontière la plus spectaculaire
du Caucase mais c'est aussi la plus
imprévisible étant donné l'altitude une
avalanche vient d'entraîner la fermeture
de la principale route du commerce qui
mène en Russie les camions sont
immobilisés sur des kilomètres et des
kilomètres dans les montagnes ces
chauffeurs vont devoir atteindre des
jours pour passer au doigt
mais ils ont l'habitude
sur cette artère névralgique depuis un
an en raison des sanctions de l'Occident
la Géorgie quoi que pro-occidentale est
devenu une plaque tournante pour la
cheminement des marchandises que la
Russie importe désormais des pays du
Caucase et de l'Asie centrale
du Tadjikistan de l'Arménie dit-il avec
des produits locaux comme des fruits des
fleurs du textile et des matériaux de
construction
ce chauffeur dit qu'il arrive lui
dérivan avec une semi-remorque remplie
de chips et pas n'importe lesquels
ce sont des Pringles
qui distribue les Pringles est une des
centaines de compagnies qui ont mis fin
à leurs activités en Russie dès le 24
février pour protester contre l'invasion
de l'Ukraine mais les Pringles sont un
des biens sous embargo qu'on retrouve
pourtant facilement à Moscou tout comme
les halfons
[Musique]
pour un distributeur arménien qui les a
importés de l'Europe et les réexportent
à son tour vers Moscou c'est ce qu'on
appelle des importations parallèles en
Russie elles sont devenues monnaie
courante depuis que le Kremlin les a
légalisés pour contrer les sanctions et
les boycottes sans le consentement des
fabricants
obsèques pas de vacanyan est un
économiste aérévan la capitale de
l'Arménie où nous étions quelques jours
avant de venir en Géorgie et où nous
avons pu facilement constater le mode de
Soper handy
d'annonces comme celle-ci
il nous a même reçu dans son parc
automobile ou son garer des modèles
flambant neufs qu'il vient d'importer de
l'Europe des États-Unis et même du
Canada en toute légalité
l'Union européenne s'inquiète d'ailleurs
de voir les statistiques d'exportation
MONT en flèche vers la Russie depuis
tous ces pays qui maintiennent leurs
liens économique avec elle en Arménie
par exemple elles ont augmenté de 77% de
moitié en Turquie
idem pour le Kazakhstan
bien qu'il soit impossible pour le
moment de déterminer quelle est
l'appareils
en vacances en Arménie
et le transit par la Géorgie quoique
long et dangereux et devenu
indispensable même si celle-ci assure
les pieds de l'Ouest qu'elle ne laisse
pas les produits sanctionnés entrés en
Russie ces camionnettes nous confient
tout bas qu'il y a dans cette ville
interminable des iPhone des ordinateurs
qui vont traverser sans problème alors
Poutine peut toujours compter sur des
voisins dociles pour braver la tempête
[Musique]
avenir une tragédie qui a façonné
l'identité ukrainienne retour sur Lolo
de mort la grande famille l'orchestrée
[Musique]
la guerre actuelle est en train de
diviser les ukrainiens et les Russes
certains disent même pour toujours mais
le ressentiment à l'égard de Moscou date
de bien plus longtemps en 1932 Staline a
provoqué volontairement une grande
famille Lolo de mort qui a fait entre 6
et 7 millions de victimes son objectif
avoué c'était d'anéantir le nationalisme
ukrainien Jean-Michel Leprince revient
sur cette tragédie qui continue de
hanter le pays
1917 l'Ukraine pour la première fois en
200 ans de domination devient
indépendante quand l'Empire russe
s'effondre pendant la Première Guerre
mondiale et la révolution bolchevique
pas pour longtemps après quatre années
de guerre civile Moscou reprend le
contrôle de l'Ancien Empire des tsar
l'Ukraine et les régions russouvrent
d'une première famine mais Lénine
réaliste lance sa nouvelle politique
économique la NEP pour rallier les
populations au bolchevisme libre marché
pour les fermiers Ukrainiens qui
constituent 80% de la population
l'Ukraine riche grenier de l'Europe
prospère à nouveau pour la première fois
depuis le 17e siècle l'église orthodoxe
ukrainienne René mais tout se fait en
ukrainien Saint Joseph Staline ne le
supporte pas après la mort de Lénine en
1924 il met en place un état centraliste
totalitaire
c'est ce qu'illustre le documentaire la
moisson du désespoir le holo de mort le
génocide ukrainien du centre
ukraino-canadien de recherche et du
documentation et donc quand on dit ça
vient de deux mots et more est mort
épuisement épuisement par la fin ou pas
la famille romane Serbie n'a rien
introduit et commenté le texte
fondamental sur le génocide ukrainien
publié en 1953 par le juriste polonais
Raphaël Lemkin en 33 langues c'est le
Kin qui a forgé la notion et le terme de
génocide codifié par les Nations Unies
en 1948 et mise en œuvre par Staline en
Ukraine et il avait préparé une
politique pour exterminer les éliminer
les élites
nationaux puis Staline confisque toutes
les terres des paysans obligés de
travailler dans les fermes collectives
l'école causes les paysans qui résistent
les koulaks sont déportés ou éliminés
toutes les récoltes de l'Ukraine sont
réquisitionnées après c'est la famille
prête en 1933 le génocide par la fin
atteint son point culminant 25000
meurent chaque jour Staline voulait-il
éliminer tous les Ukrainiens pour romane
serbine il voulait plutôt de les
transformer en D ce qu'il appelait les
lois je les vis du Grand mécanisme de
l'Empire qui était qui s'appelait à
cette époque la ligne soviétique
conclusion de Rafael Lemkin il ne s'agit
pas simplement d'un cas de meurtre de
masse il s'agit d'un cas de génocide de
destruction non seulement des individus
mais d'une culture d'une nation
le 22 novembre dernier 9 mois après
l'invasion russe le président zellenski
commémore le horlogue de mort au
mémorial du génocide en compagnie des
dirigeants de la Belgique et de la
Lituanie
cette fois-ci l'Occident semble décider
à ne pas fermer les yeux et à résister à
une nouvelle tentative Danielle et la
nation ukrainienne de nier son existence
afin de reconstituer l'ancienne empire
des tsars et de Staline
[Musique]
après la pause on retrouve nos
correspondances sur le terrain à quoi
s'attendre du conflit dans les prochains
mois
[Musique]
l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU a exigé
cet après-midi le retrait immédiat des
troupes russes en Ukraine elle a aussi
appelé à une pêche juste et durable et
justement pour terminer cette émission
un peu de perspective à quoi peut-on
s'attendre dans les prochaines semaines
les prochains mois je retrouve nos
correspondances sur le terrain et Azel
volgorghis joint à nous depuis
Washington alors Jean-François d'abord
en Ukraine après cette année de guerre
on peut se le dire plus personne ne
s'attend vraiment à une fin rapide de ce
conflit
c'est vrai que ça peut prendre du temps
mais les Ukrainiens eux sont convaincus
que le temps joue en leur faveur d'abord
il devait recevoir au printemps où elle
était c'est armes lourdes ces chars
c'est blindé promis par les pays
occidentaux ça devrait leur donner un
avantage alors qu'en face les Russes eux
continuent de perdre des temps justement
à peu près chaque jour la Russie aussi
qui a pas réussi à établir sur cette
mobilisation massive ça fait donc en
fait justement simplement juste plus
d'hommes qui rentrent en Russie que
chaque jour en dans des cercueils quand
évidemment la question du moral des
troupes l'avantage là aussi est
clairement du côté de l'Ukraine et puis
le temps aussi devrait aider les
ukrainien oui alors Tamara vous vous
continuez de couvrir l'Europe de l'Est
et les pays de l'ancien bloc soviétique
et là quel enjeu est-ce qu'il faut
surveiller
je vous dirai la Moldavie plus très
petit pays le plus pauvre de l'Europe
qui est ni membre de l'Union européenne
quoi que les candidates et ni membres de
l'OTAN à les coincée entre la Roumanie
et l'Ukraine et elle est depuis deux
semaines en état d'alerte après avoir
reçu des renseignements selon lesquels
le Kremlin voulait orchestrer un coup
d'État pour s'emparer du pouvoir et ce
sont des renseignements qui sont pris
très au sérieux par Washington joviden
en a fait mention cette semaine dans son
grand discours sur la démocratie en
Pologne donc si ce scénario devait se
produire ça donnerait très certainement
un avantage à la Russie la possibilité
d'ouvrir un nouveau front en Ukraine
donc Moldavie un pays a surveiller au
cours des prochains mois ouais on va
regarder ça de près et Marie-Ève en
Europe occidentale c'est une question
beaucoup de gens se posent est-ce que le
soutien à l'Ukraine à l'Ukraine va tenir
bon est-ce qu'il y a des fissures qui
commencent à apparaître
ces lignes depuis plus d'un an je vous
dirais que le soutien des populations
des pays membres de l'Union européenne
se maintient c'est très stable d'abord
encore aujourd'hui les gens se disent
très proche de ce conflit il le suit
avidement les gens se disent toujours
très favorable ou soutien à l'Ukraine à
l'envoi d'art mais en tout cas un
soutien militaire là où on voit qui
commence à y avoir une certaine fatigue
c'est sur l'accueil des réfugiés
Ukrainiens dans certains des pays et il
y a une exception importante à ce
soutien de façon très majoritaire aux
opérations ukrainiennes c'est la Hongrie
là depuis le tout début on voit qu'il y
a une réticence non seulement des
dirigeants mais de la population à
soutenir l'Ukraine mais sur le plan de
l'aide militaire en tout cas pour
l'instant l'Union européenne semble
parler d'une même voix surtout la
Pologne qui se découvre une voix très
importante dans ce conflit qui s'est
fait le porte-voix de cet envoi de char
et qui aujourd'hui demande des avions de
chasse pour l'Ukraine tout à fait et on
va du côté des États-Unis donc à Z on
très combatif déterminer cette semaine
en Pologne il a réaffirmé son soutien
indéfectible à l'Ukraine mais encore
faut-il qu'il conserve le soutien du
Congrès oui Céline un congrès divisé
avec une majorité républicaine à la
Chambre des Représentants on a entendu
le président Keven makassy dire que on
va pas donner un chèque en blanc à
l'Ukraine vous savez que depuis le début
de l'invasion les États-Unis envoyaient
112 milliards de dollars à l'Ukraine
plus de 60 milliards en aide militaire
elle économique près de 30 milliards de
dollars en aide humanitaire également
donc là il va y avoir beaucoup plus de
surveillance il y a des comités qui sont
formés justement pour bien s'assurer que
cet argent là soit bien dépensé en
Ukraine le cauchemar des Américains
c'est que par exemple l'équipement
militaire puisse se retrouver dans des
mauvaises mains également pour ce qui
est des salaires des fonctionnaires pour
tout ce soutien économique on veut
vraiment que l'argent arrive à
destination c'est que l'Ukraine n'est
pas à l'abri de la corruption donc c'est
ce qui va falloir surveiller demain Joe
Biden va rencontrer les membres du G7 il
va avoir d'autres sanctions économiques
mais la population ici vous savez au
début de la guerre 60% de la population
soutenait l'Ukraine si vous voulez été
derrière le soutien militaire à
l'Ukraine là c'est descendu à 48% donc
Joe Biden répète cette phrase on va
soutenir l'Ukraine azzong as été aussi
longtemps qu'il le faudra sauf que plus
cette guerre dure et plus le soutien va
peut-être se s'étioler on sait que les
Américains ont critiqué ces visites en
Ukraine en disant que Joe Biden est
beaucoup plus préoccupé par les
frontières en Ukraine que par celle de
son propre pays à cause des réfugiés
donc ce sera un peu plus difficile pour
Joe Biden
donc on va surveiller tout ça merci
beaucoup à chacun d'entre vous ça a été
très intéressant très pertinent merci
et c'est ce qui me fait à ce Téléjournal
que nous avons présenté de Kiev pour
marquer cet anniversaire de l'invasion
russe merci à toutes l'équipe merci à
vous de nous avoir suivi et on se laisse
sur des images des manifestations
d'appui aux Ukrainiens aujourd'hui un
peu partout dans le monde bonsoir à
bientôt
[Musique]